two years before the 7/7 attacks
Britain's first suicide bombers struck
Tel Aviv April 2003 three dead and more
than 50 injured people were running out
and people were on the ground glass
broken and the smell flesh the attack
carried out by two men from Hounslow and
Darby now for the first time questions
are being asked about whether apparent
links between this attack in Tel Aviv
and the July 7th London bombings have
ever been properly investigated 7-7 for
me is like it's like the continuation
bombing of my place this special case
was on me that I don't know what was the
reason for that lead 7-7 bomber Mohammad
Sidique Khan had been on the
surveillance radar from as early as 2001
but an inquest into the London attacks
found British intelligence and police
could not have reasonably been expected
to have identified him as an imminent
threat yet a potentially crucial fact
was missing from the inquests
deliberations one confirmed by senior
Israeli security officials Mohammad
Sidique Khan had visited Israel for a
single day in February 2003 just weeks
before the Mike's place attack the
tel-aviv bombers were Asif Hanif and
Omar Sharif two British citizens who had
traveled to Israel after visiting Syria
and Jordan her Neves device detonated
Sharif's failed he was found drowned on
the beach weeks later later this
martyrdom video was released claiming
they had acted on behalf of the
Palestinian militant group Hamas but
their radical connections weren't well
beyond Gaza like Mohammad Sidique Khan
the tel-aviv bombers were involved in
the u.k activities of the now banned Al
Muhajiroun group it is believed Sharif
and Khan may have visited the same
mosque in be stand over a number of
years and a BBC documentary in 2006 went
further still suggesting that Khan Omar
Sharif and Asif Hanif had together
approached a businessman in Manchester
in 2001 attempting to persuade him to
fund a project to send young Muslims for
education in Syria and Afghanistan if
Mohammed Sidique Khan visited Israel
just weeks before the bombing that took
place here and he knew the two men that
carried it out it raises the question of
whether the investigation into the
backgrounds and the network of the
Mike's place for MERS was sufficient
after Mike's place some of Charice
relatives were put on trial for
withholding information one was cleared
and two others had cases dropped no one
has ever been convicted in the UK for
connection to the tel-aviv attacks okay
let's go walk in and out of Israel for
Joshua Fordham there's always been
questions about the British response to
what happened at Mike's place he was
working as a barman when the bombing
took place who's also filming a
documentary about the bar itself I had
about 30 hours of footage that I had
collected about a week or two before
before the bombing and of course the
night of the bombing I remember I filmed
at least two hours of footage the
footage was of understandable interest
to the authorities in his recently
published graphic novel about the
attacks he recounts an interview with
Israeli intelligence before they sent me
off they said the British Secret Service
are going to be getting in contact with
you in the next few days because they
want to interview you and they want to
see your tapes please please cooperate
with them and I said to them absolutely
and basically the the end of the meeting
was basically them saying to me this is
their problem they had my details and
they said that they passed it on and I
never ever heard from them after seven
seven Israeli authorities looked into
whether Khan's visit to Israel was part
of the planning for the Mike's place
attacks they've since said there were no
findings to corroborate this but was it
really just a tourist trip analysts
speculate Khan's use of Allenby crossing
with Jordan may have been to scout the
security at the crossing itself why
because they believed the Mike's placed
bombers used this crossing to smuggle in
explosives they picked up in Syria most
95 even more than that of the explosive
charges that were used in the suicide
attacks and all that
ethics were based on improvised
explosives a assembled and produced in
the backyard of a Palestinian residence
and here we are finding something
professional prepared very well unless
Barak Benzer once held a senior position
in the shin BET's he throws equivalent
of MLA 5 he says the Mike's place attack
was unique it should have raised alarm
bells across the board if we are looking
to the Hamas at that period of time
there were no need for any foreigners to
join their a campaign of suicide attack
so bringing two people in such a long
way to Tel Aviv in order to carry out
the suicide attack it was very peculiar
and he surprised the possible connection
of Mohammed Sidique Khan has never been
publicly examined by the post 7-7
inquiries this case was not mentioned
there are a variety of other cases that
the the rebels deal with they're very
deeply and very let's say seriously but
this special case was omitted I don't
know what was the reason for that the
government's official account of 7-7
said there was no evidence of anything
suspicious about Khan's visit to Israel
however there is a crucial omission from
this report at no point does it record
anything about the Mike's place attacks
indeed in its timeline of global acts of
terror Britain's first ever suicide
bombers do not feature at all the
coroner who led the 7/7 inquest said she
believed she'd left no stone unturned
but a lawyer who represented the
majority of the victims families during
those proceedings has told Sky News he
would have asked her to look into the
Israel trip had his team been aware of
it now the chairman of the Home Affairs
Select Committee says further actions
should be taken it is relevant because
the relatives of the victims of 7-7
believe it is relevant and since it was
not in the original timeline
does need to be considered and I shall
be writing to the Home Secretary to ask
whether she agrees with that and to get
an explanation as to why this
information was not put before the
reports in the first place
it seems the question of links between
Muhammad Sadiq Khan and the tel-aviv
bombing has not even been asked let
alone answered Tom Rainer Sky News
Jerusalem